[Musik]
es ist samstagabend es ist ein abend von
nikolaus und sie haben ganz genau
richtig eingeschaltet zum emotionalsten
herzergreifenden und auch prominentesten
teppich der ein herz für kinder gala
ganz richtig sind sie hier herzlich
willkommen anderthalb stunden jetzt
hochkarätige gäste herzlich willkommen
auch dir herzlich willkommen martin ja
auch in diesem nicht ganz einfachen
corona jahr wollen wir natürlich zurück
geben und das mit ihrer hilfe heute geht
es um spenden für die allerkleinsten bei
der großen ein herz für kinder
spendengala und da können sie ganz
besonders mithelfen aber auch wenn sich
vieles geändert hat in diesen zeiten wir
sehen uns hier dran schon eins hat sich
bei dieser gala trotzdem nicht geändert
ja trotz dieser windschutzscheibe hier
zwischen unis die hochkarätigen gäste
die haben sich nicht geändert die kommen
natürlich für sie in den nächsten
anderthalb stunden hier rüber und ich
möchte sagen sie können sich auf einige
freund zum beispiel sylvie malz wladimir
klitschko
michael patrick kelly elias m'barek ist
dabei und sophia und simone thomalla
aber das ist noch nicht alles genau weil
bei denen es dann auch loris karius
dabei und auch sonst aus so vielen
branchen haben wir leute hier ich muss
auch einmal auf meinen zug ohne mich
niemand vergessen max raabe mit dem
shooting star lea auch später auf der
bühne und natürlich hier auf dem teppich
tv moderatorin nazan eckes aus der
schweiz der rapstar überhaupt loredana
hierbei ein herz für kinder und zum
aller ersten mal live bei ein herz für
kinder auch florian silbereisen
stichwort florian silbereisen da kommt
einem sofort eine dame in den kopf ein
man kann einen schon sagen weltstar oder
das ist unser deutscher welt-star helene
fischer es ist ihr erster großer
auftritt heute abend hier sein herz für
kinder und bevor sie später in der
spendengala zwei passende zwei songs
performen wird also alle fans können
sich freuen nicht nur ein song zwei
songs
never enough und einmal in the prayer
mit andrea bocelli wird sie hoffentlich
auch hier über den roten teppich kommen
ja und das allerwichtigste ich kann es
gar nicht oft genug sagen heute geht es
natürlich um spenden dafür sind all
diese promis hier
dafür sind wir hoffentlich auch sie
jetzt denn es geht um spenden und zwar
gibt es genau eine nummer die sie sich
heute aber merkt müssen es die 0 18 02
10 10 10 oder dieser nummer können sie
anrufen alle prominenten sitzen später
an den telefon um ihre spenden
entgegenzunehmen und das allerwichtigste
neben der nummer ist zu wissen wirklich
jeder cent den sie spenden der kommt bei
den kleinsten an der kommt bei den
kindern an jeder cent zählt hier war ein
herz für kinder und jeder cent kommt
wirklich an wie nele eben schon gesagt
habe 0 18 02 10 10 10 ist ihre nummer da
können sie natürlich jetzt schon anrufen
auf jeden fall da sie gehen einfach aus
ins internet unter www.fh da steht ein
für ein herz für kinder natürlich
punkt.de und auch da können sie spenden
es gibt natürlich auch andere wege und
sich ein telefon zur hand haben dann
können sie natürlich über pv zum
beispiel spenden auf www hna fh.de
können sie das tun
ich würde aber schon anrufen denn wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe und man
heute abend zum hörer greift und ein
bisschen glück habt und helene fischer
fern zb ist dann kommt man persönlich
bei frau fischer am apparat raus ist das
so also helene fischer sitzt auch an
unserem spendentelefon mit ein bisschen
glück landet man also bei ihr kann bei
ihr ihre eigene spende abgeben
aber selbst wenn es mich helene ist es
wird hier gleich zu sehen sein auf dem
roten teppich gewinnen wir alles heute
hier und noch mal die sitzung alle an
dem telefon man kann also bei heiko
hohmann lochmann landen man kann bei
wladimir klitschko nannten man kann bei
so vielen menschen heute am landen und
das wichtigste ist man tut das natürlich
für die kinder heute geht es nur um die
allerkleinsten den wir auf der ganzen
welt helfen wollen und jetzt fragt sich
der ein oder andere da draußen
vielleicht die beiden was ist mit den
los die stehen hier so dicht beieinander
und haben keine maske erstens wir haben
natürlich ein crooner schnelltest
gemacht also wir sind beide negative
beide haben nichts und
wir hier auf diesen teppich heute sind
alle wohn vorher getestet denn natürlich
die sicherheit geht in diesen zeiten
noch immer vor das werden sie auch
gleich sehen wenn die ersten promis zu
uns kommen dann wird hier ein
mindestabstand natürlich gehalten und
wir beide haben diese schicke
plexiglasscheibe es ist so ein bisschen
wie im drive-in oder ja es ist so ein
bisschen was möchten sie bestellen werde
so der vorne stehen sie schon die
valerie niehaus und die franziska knuppe
in einem kleid wie würdest du das
beschreiben so wie wir aus einem
blumenstrauß sagen jetzt die macht schon
nicht mehr das schönste kleid neben dir
war es noch einfach oder dann gleich zu
beginn kommt johann in einem traumhaften
kleid aber das ist ein richtiger teaser
für sie bleiben sie dran
bis sie hier ist kann aber noch einmal
die wichtigsten nummer des abends sein
weil die darf man einfach nicht
vergessen hatte 0 18 02 10 10 10 das ist
ihre nummer bisher wurden schon 355
millionen euro bei ein herz gehirn ein
herz für kinder gesammelt das muss man
sich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen
355 millionen euro und letztes jahr gab
es eine summe die gilt es dieses jahr zu
toppen 18 millionen 97.500 86 millionen
das ist auch ordentlich und ich hoffe
heute abend kommen wir mindestens auf
die 19 millionen meinst du wir schaffen
das ich hoffe natürlich sehr und das
ganze dann im zdf 20.15 die große
spendengala aber auch hierbei bild zu
sehen wenn sie dann dran bleiben und man
muss sagen diese gala die es das 42 10
mal und jedes mal ist es wirklich ein
feuerwerk wasser ab gezündet wird
und das ändert sich auch in corona
zeiten nicht helene wir uns gerade schon
sagt steht auf der bühne
max rabl zusammen mit lea viele viele
auftritte und auch viele viele
geschichten leider auch sehr traurige
bewegende schicksale die wir ihnen
zeigen wollen um auch zu zeigen wo das
geld dann landet das sie heute abend
hoffentlich spenden um zu sagen zeigen
was für schicksale sie damit ja berühren
können was wir leben sie damit verändern
können nicht nur die fischer nicht nur
florian silbereisen nicht nur thomas
anders wir haben silvia sofia und simone
thomalla andrea bocelli uschi glas
verona pooth elias amberg manuela
schwesig auch ein bisschen hier was
für die politische bildung manchmal
kommt auch jetzt sparen richtig genau
und aus der ganz andere richtung muss
man sagen wir haben loredana da rapstar
natürlich musst du dich am meisten oder
ich hab's vielleicht loredana kommt wir
haben diese an lena hier wir haben heike
und roman lochmann da wir haben sarah
und dominik er ist also durchaus alle in
richtung in die die hallervorden jump
ist barbara schöneberger
also wir kommen hier gar nicht aus dem
namen raus das shopping und der teppich
fühlt sich auch mal weiter aber wenn man
fühlens seite muss man noch mal betont
natürlich das ganze unter coroner
bedingungen heute alle sind getestet die
hier sind wir haben hier unsere kleine
abtrennung und da wird natürlich darauf
geachtet deswegen leider dieses mal ohne
zuschauer das ganze aber sie kann es
natürlich bei bett und auf zdf verfolgen
da können sie sich auch schon freuen
übrigen wir haben vorhin schon mal kurz
und die probe reinschauen dürfen und es
sieht alles ganz anders aus aber es
sieht auch so aus na also da wo sonst
das publikum sitzt müssen sie sich
vorstellen stehen viele couch und
natürlich mit dem gebürtigen
mindestabstand und da werden die promis
auch platz nehmen wenn sie nicht gerade
telefonieren und da wird auch klassische
sagt barbara schöneberger auch dieses
jahr für die spenden gab sie geben
schüler spenden sammeln und da vorne
sind schon franziska knuppe die können
wir vielleicht auch gleich noch mal
zeigen und da sehen sie auch schon das
ist ein ordentlicher abstand es ist
anders als es sonst hierbei ein herz für
kinder abläuft und auch anders als sonst
an einem roten teppich abläuft weil man
war der letzte rote teppich zur fashion
week würde ich sagen in diesem jahr und
das war anfang januar ist es wirklich
der erste große rote teppich und auch
der letzte große rote teppich in diesem
jahr ist ja auch der wichtigste ab
sowieso sowieso dieses jahr war nicht
einfach aber der wichtigste teppich den
gibt es trotzdem vor allem um den
kindern zu helfen
ja und jetzt sagen wir noch mal die
nummer ich werde dich heute damit nicht
in ruhe lassen so oft in halle sogar
ihre ich die spenden nummer sagt uns
noch einmal wie kann man heute am
allerbesten spende und vor allem
vielleicht bei so vielen anderen gerade
sehe oder helene fischer am telefon
landen
ich muss sagen du siehst mehr als ich
sehe immer noch franziska knuppe in
diesem traum aus etwa die nummer bevor
du weiter
rosenblätter aber ich kann mich kaum
konzentrieren aber die nummer die
verkehrsdichte das ist die 0 18 02 10 10
10 das ist die nummer die rufen sie
einfach an und dann kommen sie direkt
entweder bei einem promi raus oder
natürlich auch bei irgendeinem netten
mitarbeiter von ein herz für kinder und
jeder cent zählt es ist doch ganz egal
ob sie nur fünf euro und spenden wollen
jeder cent kommt bei den kindern an wenn
sie die 0 18 02 10 10 10 wählen und
jetzt war ich so ein bisschen yorker
zeit erreicht weil ich dachte franziska
knuppe kommt auf uns zugerannt ihre
hoffentlich haben für mich als er war
okay das ist hat sie nicht reden ich
muss auch sagen vielleicht kann man auch
manchmal kurz dinge zeigen ja das ist ja
im ganzen ein tannenbaum ein tannenbaum
der herzen sage ich jetzt schon ja da
ist der bugatti nein da ist der kantor
des cups nicht aber du siehst auch toll
aus dem anlass entsprechend weil es ist
ja die große spendengala auch wenn alles
ein bisschen anders ist das darf man
nicht vergessen
das hat tradition seit 42 jahren ist das
hier eine tradition und das kann
natürlich auch in diesem jahr das für
niemanden von uns einfach war vergessen
werden denn auch dieses jahr ist es so
wichtig den kindern den hilflosen den
kleinsten zu helfen und diese zu
unterstützen und falls sie sich gerade
wundern wenn wir uns mal so 12 mal ins
wort fallen ja das liegt nicht daran
dass wir beide schwerhörig sind oder
nicht mitkriegen dass der andere nicht
redet sondern es liegt wirklich an
dieser schutzwand die nicht umsonst da
ist aber die knallt auch ziemlich viel
schall nicht hörst du mich nehmen als 8
02 10 10 10 und gleich steht franziska
knuppe die es gerade noch bei den
kollegen von prosieben und da hinten
sehe ich schon simone thomalla und
sophia thomalla vierte mal und ihr
fußballer norris kann ich dazu wollte
ich fast sagen um gottes willen damit
hätte ich da nicht jeder andere aber
gestern hat seine mannschaft hier in
berlin noch das derby gespielt leider
auch noch immer ohne zuschauer
heute dann die groß sein herz für kinder
spendengala und das dann auch leider
ohne zuschauer aber wir haben hier
schauer im stadion sich fast sagt
in der halle denn sie können zu schauen
die ganze spendengala ab 20 15
sowohl hierauf beet als auch im zdf da
verpassen sie gar nicht so und bei ein
herz für kinder ist alles knallrot und
auch dieses kleid ist knallrot ich dafür
begrüßen
jetzt am roten teppich dagmar wöhrl
kommen sie ruhig noch ein bisschen
dichter vor wir gucken sie da vorne ist
extra eine schwarze markierung alles ein
bisschen anders in diesem jahr
verstehen sie mich von hier wissen ja
das ist herrlich jetzt höre ich die auch
ein bisschen übers mikro dlv will sie
sind nicht das erste mal ein herz für
kinder was bedeutet ihnen diese
veranstaltung
ich glaube sehr sehr wichtige
veranstaltung wir sind froh dass sie sie
gibt sonst müsste man sie wirklich
erfinden weil sie immer wieder den
finger in die wunde legt war das immer
wichtig immer wieder daran zu erinnern
dass wir aus unserer wohl komfortzone
heraus müssen und über den tellerrand
schauen müssen
nun ist es ein ganz besonderes jahr
corona bedingt wie haben sie 2020 erlebt
das war ein außergewöhnliches jahr was
man eigentlich nicht mehr so erleben
möchte glaube ich ich vor allem weil ich
habe sehr viele soziale projekte auch im
ausland ist sehr sehr schwer wenn sie
ihre kinder die sie betreuen nicht
besuchen können wenn sie alles nur über
über video machen müssen und alles um
die kinder einfach nicht benehmen können
das ist unwahrscheinlich wie sieht darin
weihnachten aus ja sehr minimiert dieses
mal dass der see minimiert also leider
nur drei ich habe eine 95 jährige mutter
die ich leider dieses mal nicht zu mir
holen kann weil die bettlägerig ist und
das tut
märz dann oder aber dann hoffen wir dass
es das vorbei geht und dass das nächste
weihnachten ja hoffentlich und das alles
und vor allem ich freue mich dass wir
heute abend sehr sehr viel geld wieder
spenden und wieder viele kinderaugen zum
leuchten bringen wäre aber sind sie alle
hätten wir auch zusätzlich eine lena
fischer sind sie einen fischer finja ich
hätte sehr gerne ist dass sie heute
abend zwar sehr schöner wirklich ganz
viel spaß den ich erst mal ein herz für
kinder und vielleicht ein ganz klein
aufruf in diese kamera ganz zum schluss
machen diese kamera und da sind wir
drauf da sind sie ja drauf ich freue
mich dass sie zugeschaut
haben und bitte denken sie tragen wir
können zwar die welt nicht retten aber
wir können mit einem kleinen schritt
können wir sie besser machen deswegen
spenden sie bitte frau bevor sie sagen
dass sie heute abend hier sehe ich den
gerne macht mir sehr viel freude
dankeschön toll aus das wollte ich noch
sagen ein traum in rot und gleich als
nächstes oder es uns jetzt ist uns jetzt
etwa die frau gruppe durch die lappen
gegangen
ich freute mich laut sagen ich dachte
vielleicht merkt es nicht und dann ist
das sie kommt wieder das noch bekommen
einfach da vorne auf die cloud das
schwarze kurzfristig nicht wieder machen
technisch nicht alles richten martin hat
den ganzen teppich schon nur darüber
geredet wie toll du heute aus sie ist
ein traum in rot vielen lieben dank
danke warum ist es dir so wichtig vor
allem auch in diesem jahr das wirklich
für niemanden einfach heute abend hier
zu sein und die allerkleinsten zu
unterstützen
ich glaube dass in diesem jahr die
kinder aufgrund der ganzen situation
wirklich am meisten gelitten haben
weil also meine tochter zum beispiel 13
sie versteht mittlerweile worum es geht
aber die meisten kinder wissen ja gar
nicht worum es hier geht warum warum man
nicht rausgehen darf warum er nicht
spielen darf mit seinen freunden warum
man jetzt nicht die große
geburtstagsparty mit opa feiern darf und
dass den klar zu machen oder einfach zu
sagen du bleibst der ziele und das
daneben auch zuhause irgendwie denen
wieder so schön wie möglich zu machen
mit schule mit spielen mit allem was
dazugehört war unwahrscheinlich
schwierig jetzt versuchen wir natürlich
bei ein herz für kinder immer auch einen
positiven ausblick auf viele sachen zu
machen sind bewegende schicksale
schreckliche schicksale die wir hier oft
begleiten was ist das positivste was du
aus diesem jahr trotzdem mitnehmen
kannst 2020 was war der lichtblick
also ich finde ich kann ja nur in dem
moment über meine familie sprechen und
ich glaube dass in diesem jahr unsere
familien noch mehr zusammengerückt ist
weil wir uns einfach weil einfach diese
routine mit schule und arbeiten und nach
hause kommen und wieder wegfahren dies
natürlich weggefallen und dadurch musste
man also im positiven sinne einfach
zusammenrücken und sich auf die nur auf
die familie konzentrieren und ich glaube
dass es einigen schwer gefallen
bei uns war das doch wirklich sehr
positiv muss ich sagen sag uns jetzt
noch einmal herz für kinder ganz
allgemein warum liegt ihr dieses projekt
diese stiftung so am herzen herz für
kinder liegt mir seit jahren schon
wahnsinnig am herzen weil wirklich die
kleinsten die unterstützung von uns
brauchen
sei es weil sie krank sind sei es weil
sie aufgrund von armut
aufgrund von der sozialen gegebenheit
vielleicht ihre eltern nicht das machen
können was sie ja auch was andere kinder
machen und dafür ist ein herz für kinder
dar um die zu unterstützen und ihnen
einen lichtblick zu geben
das ist auf jeden fall nicht am meisten
heute abend helene fischer florian
silbereisen andrea bocelli
das haben telefon sitzen denn all die
tollen spenden entgegennehmen können das
ist die beste antwort kannst du in diese
kamera auch noch einen ganz eigenen
spendenaufruf machen wir wollen
natürlich so viel geld wie möglich heute
bekommen
also liebe zuschauer an den fernsehern
oder an den sozialen medien in den
sozialen medien spendet was das zeug
hält ist jetzt am telefon und nehmen die
spende hingegen mit ganz ganz vielen
anderen prominenten und einer tollen
show viel spaß und die nummer dazu ist
sie nur 18 02 10 10 10 und dann haben
sie vielleicht franziska knuppe am hörer
doch toll oder
wir freuen uns sehr dass du da warst da
gefangen ist dafür sparen
wir gucken mal wenn wir da vorne haben
simone und ziernähten simone ist kann
ich dabei ist es anne sophie mutter
sophia thomalla mit loris karius
dahinter elena karriere wenn ich das
sehe aber hier geht es direkt weiter mit
euro gefordert tat aus kommissarin fall
begrüße sie wieder aussieht stehen
perfekt das ist als quotenfrau folgert
wie sieht's aus sie sind schon mehrere
male bei ein herz für kinder gewesen was
macht ein herz für kinder so bedeutsam
für sie
kinder was muss ich habe mir sagen
kinder auf dieser welt sind das
schwächste glied die brauchen unsere
unterstützung die geraten gerade in
diesem chor unter zeiten glaube ich noch
mehr ins hintertreffen
es gibt noch mehr kinderarbeit arbeit
noch mehr kinderarmut das ist schon
besorgniserregend und deswegen finde ich
diese veranstaltung wahnsinnig wichtig
und ich glaube es tut auch gut zu helfen
etwas mal über den tellerrand zu schauen
und sich um andere gedanken zu machen
und was herzugeben
wir haben gerade mit doch mal wird
gesprochen werden franziska muth
gesprochen haben alle gesagt natürlich
sieht weihnachten bei ihnen anders aus
und vielleicht sogar auch schon nikolaus
wieder zuhause folkerts sein
ich bin nicht so einem fall seien
weihnachts krieg mit baum und kitsch und
sollen wir ihn schnell abholzen winter
hinein
und der passt ja gut ich hab dann auch
gerne jetzt heute als läge mir reicht
eigentlich gemütliche kleine runde wir
haben uns auch schon geeinigt wer
einander sieht es ist immer die sache
ich habe noch eltern meine mutter hat
vorher geburtstag
da mache ich einen schnelltest und wie
sie unbedingt besuchen die wird 85 und
meine schwester macht damit ihr
weihnachten
das sind kleine kreise aber es ist
einfach auch um das risiko so gering wie
möglich zu halten
und ich finde das kann man mal auf sich
nehmen auch wenn die eltern ist so alt
und man natürlich denkt dann ist das das
letzte weihnachten aber ich nehme meine
mutter war zum geburtstag meine
schwester zu weihnachten das ist legal
verdecken aufteilung es ist für sie in
diesem jahr schon vorbei oder arbeit
drehen sie noch nein ich drehe nicht
mehr
auch dreh nicht mehr und bin auch nicht
heiß drauf gerade weil man kann nicht
lüften man kann nicht draußen
herumstehen und an der frischen luft
sein man muss jeden tag tests machen
es tauchen doch immer mehr positive
fälle auf drews müssen unterbrochen
werden es ist schon prekär aber ich habe
dieses jahr gearbeitet ich bin eine der
glücklichen die das beiseite geschafft
hat und irgendwie jetzt über diesen
winter hinweg kommen wird und ich hoffe
dass es nächstes jahr
mit den reden wieder weiter gehen wird
wir hoffen das nächste jahr das normale
leben wieder und lagen so glaube ich
nicht
und so schaffen heute geht's natürlich
wir können natürlich hoffen und sehen
und das dürfen wir auch alle aber ich
glaube wir müssen noch eine weile
durchhalten hoffnung beten tun wir heute
vor allem dass ganz viel geld für die
kleinste das also
vielen vielen dank dass auch hier heute
abend hier sind und das ganze
unterstützen
der angeschuldigte sei dank kein
weihnachtsbaum das motto schönste an
weihnachten ich hörte ich immer noch
nicht
was sagst du weihnachtsbaum ja ist doch
wundert mich habe ich selten gehört ja
aber das ist logisch merkel also drin da
ist so geschmäcker sind verschieden ich
habe meinen weihnachtsbaum genug hast
dich voll kraft sagen ich habe meine
persönlichen weihnachtsbaum der herzen
hier gerade neben mich zu stehen also
ist alles gut und jetzt kommt schon der
nächste prominente gab eine erste man
heute bei uns in der sendung als gast
dann roland kranken werden schon dagmar
wöhrl wir haben jetzt frank theelen nele
bitteschön der erste band dann bist du
dran
natürlich es ist natürlich die
wichtigste frage des abends auch in
diesem corona ja wo viele viele leute
sich auch persönliche eigene probleme
hatten warum ist es so wichtig heute
abend trotzdem an zu rufen zu spenden
für die allerkleinsten haben ich glaube
dass corona ist natürlich eine pandemie
krise aber ich glaube sie leider das
denen die ich schon vorher
herausforderungen hatten es noch viel
schlimmer getroffen hat wenn man zum
beispiel meinen bereichen in die
technologie reinschaut
dann hatten wir leider ein gutes jahr
muss man ja fast sagen dass einfach
viele empfinden es als unfair und von
daher glaube ich ist dieses jahr
wichtigste spende ich selber werde auch
spenden weil ist einfach leute gibt die
können da nichts für und die hatten
vielleicht schon vor herausforderungen
und deswegen dieses jahr wichtiger denn
je
während ganz besonders geht es natürlich
um die kinder um die allerkleinsten
warum ist das eine herzensangelegenheit
für sie kinder sind unsere zukunft ich
glaube kinder sollten jedem oder
hoffentlich leben wirklich am herzen
liegen und gerade die wenn die in not
geraten dann können die ja wirklich gar
nichts dafür also bei erwachsen kann man
vielleicht doch sagen hey da habe ich
hart gearbeitet und nicht genug versucht
aber hey die kinder die können wirklich
gar nichts dafür wo sie geboren werden
wir alle am glück einfach hier in so
einem schönen land und anderen schönen
land geboren sein und das liegt einfach
sehr am herzen
es hat gerade hier vor rät darin gesagt
den weihnachtsbaum gibt es bei ihren
weihnachten nicht wie sieht ihr
weihnachten ausbauen jetzt in diesem
jahr anders
zwei weihnachtsbäume also bei uns ist ja
es gibt einen weihnachtsbaum und wird
eigentlich in weihnachten wie jedes jahr
das habe ich in ruhe mit meiner hand
meiner frau und bei uns wird da glaube
ich nicht viel ändern
sehr gut kennen sie vielleicht noch
einen spendenaufruf erst einmal machen
wir wollen natürlich so viel geld wie
möglich heute am sammeln also bitte
bitte ganz viele sitzen am telefon
freunde welchen anruf natürlich auch
online bitte spendet denn es ist
wirklich von herzen ernst gemeint dieses
jahr haben viele kinder noch größer
herausfordernd für diese noch weniger
können also ich freue mich wirklich über
jede spende ganz herzlichen dank
da kann man nichts mehr zu sagen vielen
vielen dank angehen dass auch sie heute
abend hier dabei sind dank sagen für
schön danke frank thiel ist zum beispiel
auch jemand einmal schnell durch die
kamera durch den könnten sie wenn sie
die 0 18 02 10 10 10 anrufen
auch an der strippe haben und auch
dieses gut aussehende pärchen dass
gerade hier das schwarze kreuz als ob
wir es markiert hätten betreten haben
sophia thomalla und loris karius das ist
da das ist eure kamera südost du siehst
toll aus und du bist immer dabei ein
herz für kinder liegt dir sehr am herzen
ein herzensprojekt sag uns warum und vor
allem warum in diesem jahr stehen leuten
geht es ja dieses ja nicht so gut und
trotzdem wollen wir das alle alle
spenden weil es da den aufruf für also
mein aufruf dafür also ich kann sich
findet in zeiten wie diesen besonders
wichtig dass wir das in wie schon auf
die beine stellen können dass wir so
eine veranstaltung machen mit so einer
sondergenehmigung und ich weiß auch dass
bei einigen leuten bestimmt dieses jahr
auch das geld ein bisschen knapp ist
wir haben alle vielleicht nicht so viel
gearbeitet wie wir sonst arbeiten aber
ich glaube und wenn es diesmal nicht bei
dem 100 euro sind sondern dass man nur
zehn und wenn es bei dem einheitlich
10.000 sind sondern vielleicht nur 1000
je nach portemonnaie finde ich ist es an
sich schon mal eine gute sache trotzdem
und jeder cent zählt auf jeden fall
hast du da so einen kleinen trick also
wenn dich jemand anruft du hast jemanden
an der strippe überzeugt du da noch im
letzten moment und sagst noch so fünf
euro kunst noch sein na ja also ich sag
mal schon also wenn leute mich in die an
der strippe aber die sagen ich würde
gerne 45 euro spenden kommen noch mal
eine runde sache draus war es mit 50 so
so das mache ich schon aber wenn ihr
jetzt einer sachspende 100 euro und ich
dann sage ich nicht wiederkommt zwei
hunde werden schon besser ist es
irgendwie ist es unpassend
die versuche herzlich kinder natürlich
immer auch einen positiven ausblick
zügiger die vielen geschichten hier und
loris vielleicht kannst du erzählen in
diesem jahr es war kein einfaches jahr
für niemanden aber was war so dein licht
blick vielleicht ein highlight in diesem
schweren corona ja wir haben die
anfangszeit war ich noch in istanbul
wo das alles so richtig losging und dann
ja sind wir so mitte mai zusammen nach
deutschland kommen wieder zu unseren
familien haben die da auch lange zeit
nicht gesehen haben den ersten lockdown
der kompletten der türkei verbracht das
war dann schön einfach wieder mit der
familie zu sein da mit dem ei und sonst
ja wir haben alles gut und schön
überstanden wir sind gesund ist das
wichtigste
unsere familien jetzt gut ich meine dass
in so einer zeit da schon das wichtigste
unsere lichtblick würde ich mal sagen
und hinter sich hat in dem ungewohnten
umgebung also wenn er sich in
deutschland zu hause sondern ist der
virus der kamen gerade wir wussten wenig
einzuschätzen wir wussten den internen
notierte er wir wussten nicht wie wird
er behandelt in die fan schlimm wird es
wenn man dann in der türkei fest denkt
und denkt okay was ist denn wenn es mich
ist rift bin ich hier dann überhaupt
sagen wir mal also kranken technisch bin
ich denn hier gut aufgestellt oder war
versorgt dann macht es mit einem schon
was anderes als wenn ich jetzt in
deutschland wäre und deswegen war das
für uns glaube ich schon ein wichtiger
moment in dem moment wo man uns dann
auch sagen durfte er dürfte den flieger
steigen und hause jetzt steht ihr schon
so schön vor unserem baum weihnachten
steht vor der tür morgens aber schon
nikolaus wie sie weihnachten bei euch
dieses jahr aus bisschen anders oder
passt sowieso alles die tradition die
man jedes jahr hat meine großmutter
klingt sich aus tatsächlich dieses jahr
sie ist einfach klar sie wird jetzt 80
jemand für sie ist es auch so eine
situation die hat einfach angst und das
ist vollkommen berechtigt und deswegen
wird also wenigstens ein tablet oder
vertrauen oder irgendwas können wir euch
eigentlich als tagesmutter gehört jetzt
nicht zu der generation die sagt guck
mal hier mein iphone
so ist hier ein löschen nicht aber mein
onkel ist bei ihr und den kann ich sein
facetime mäßig anrufen
sonst keine ahnung werden wir die freie
zeit genießen so viel freiheit teil gibt
es jetzt nicht wie ihnen geht schneller
los als wir mich ich kann die beine noch
ein bisschen länger hinterlegen sie
kennen eine sehr emotionale
veranstaltung wie sieht das bei euch
beiden aus nah am wasser gebaut ich habe
heute das erste mal beim corona teske
wein als mir das stäbchen bis hinten
reingeschoben wurde wie sieht es bei
euch aus wenn ihr nachher die
kinderschicksale seht hilft da die maske
heute vielleicht sogar so wird ein
schirm auf jeden fall
ich meine wir haben jetzt selber zwar
noch keine kinder aber wollen wir auf
jeden fall mal haben werden derzeit so
weit ist aber klar kinder
sind das schönste überhaupt und
natürlich berührt was ebenso schon
gelächelt du hast das nicht von zum
ersten mal diesem grund fährt gerade auf
die morgen könnte natürlich auch wie
johannes wimmer der natürlich auch bei
uns im management ist das sind fälle
natürlich über die man ein bisschen
genauer bescheid weiß und wenn man so
was dann natürlich auch privat
mitverfolgt und danach auf der bühne
natürlich mit verfolgen muss in
anführungsstrichen dann ist das auch
noch mal so ein ausnahmezustand und ich
glaube schon dass ich heute die eine
oder andere klinik box neben mir
gebrauchen könnte vielen vielen dank
dass ihr heute abend dabei sein und uns
helfen noch mehr geld fehlt dann klein
ich habe noch eine frage die ich nicht
jedes jahr stellt sofia duplex kann
darauf jedes jahr eine antwort was denn
er hat in diesem jahr kein geschenk
verdienen für dich da ich hier keine
geschenke geschenk war ja außer dass
bewohner wird weil das ohnehin nicht
also kein geschenk wer hat so wenn ich
jetzt anfangen würde dann würde ich
jetzt bis morgen noch hier stehen wer
kein geschenk verdient hatte
explizit kein geschenk
was muss man etwas bösartiges muss mir
doch was einfallen warum vettel nichts
bösartiges 1
auch geht vielleicht haben wir müssen
zuerst wiederholen ich bilde dich lange
und ich will dich auch nicht lange ganz
kleinen den letzten aufruf darüber dass
so alle sorgen ein letzter aufruf
denn diese kamera unbedingt liebe
zuschauer ich weiß es war ein hartes
jahr aber wenn sie den einen oder
anderen euro haben zwei euro drei euro
vielleicht sind auch zehn euro wenn sie
die locker machen können
für ein herz für kinder ist wirklich
eine gute sache dann wäre ich ihnen sehr
dankbar mit 0 18 02 10 10 sehen dann
haben sie simone thomalla und für lahm
ist immer noch die 4 thomas duscha
geschenk heute mach ich jetzt die
verabschiedung fielen die hat meine und
loris karius dass ihr heute abend hier
seid danke sage schon viel spaß kommt
auch für solche so noch diese frage
übrigen ja in so schwierigen jahr hat
jeder erstmal wieder hast du das gerade
gehört nein wollen kinder hast und das
habe ich glaube ich dachte was von
hinten gerufen worden ist das habe ich
gehört was hab ich genau wahrgenommen
das wären wir weiter beobachten wie
sieht's aus aber sie hat auch
angesprochen johannes wimmer ist bei ihr
management ein teil der sie sehr bewegt
hat ein pfeil über den wir heute abend
auch in der großen spendengala dann
sprechen bzw
dr wimmer selber spricht über das
schicksal seiner familie seine kleine
tochter war schwer krank ist leider
verstorben er wird heute darüber
sprechen um eben ihnen sagen zu können
warum es so wichtig ist dass möglichst
viel geld zusammenkommt damit es in die
forschung zum beispiel gehen kann damit
nicht noch mehr kinder an solch einer
krankheit verstehen müssten aber mehr
dazu erzählt er natürlich selber später
in der großen spendengala aber dass
eines der vielen schicksal über die wir
heute dann sprechen wollen und eine dame
die auch schon sehr viele schicksale
hier begleitet hat über die jahre ein
herz für kinder sich dahin schon
schon auf dem roten teppich und zwar ist
sie heute in begleitung ihrer kompletten
familie bekommen bekommen verona pooth
mit franjo mit santiago und jetzt habe
ich gerade den namen von ganz kleinen
vergessen little boots sagen wir mal und
hier vorne ein traum
eigentlich bin ich noch witze ist sylvie
meister wie komm zu uns nach vorne
da ist ein da vorne ist passend zu dem
kleid auch der schwarze strich und hier
ist eine kamera
herzlich willkommen beim hartz iv kinder
danken ein alter hase das kann man so
sagen was befindet
was bedeutet dir diese show warum jedes
jahr immer wieder dabei ja wenn man
selber mutter ist aber auch wenn man
selber keine kinder hat dann weiß man
einfach dass die kinder unsere zukunft
sind und wir müssen diese kleine wunder
die wir haben das wichtigste in unserem
leben müssen wir supporten unterstützten
schützen also das ist so so unheimlich
wichtig und ich bin so glücklich und
dankbar dass diese veranstaltung dieses
jahr dann trotz corona doch stattfindet
weil wir müssen und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass auch in dieser zeit viele
kinder leider es ganz schwer haben die
kinder familie
hier in deutschland aber auch weltweit
und ein herz für kinder macht da so ein
großartiger kunst wie man hört sich so
scheiße es ist schwierig ja kunst das
corona ja wie hat es deine familie wie
hast du das ganze mit bekommen wir auch
sein sohn das erlebt was das hier ein
meer aus
also ich glaube die uns allen ist corona
ja 1 1 ein drama für mich in mein
familienleben hat das bedeutet dass es
ganz schwierig ist alles zu sehen
wir leben alle so dass niemand über
europa meine eltern in belgien
mein bruder in amsterdam holland mein
kind in dänemark wir sind in hamburg
es ist schon sehr sehr schwierig und es
ist hart
ja uns weihnachten wird es ja auch
nichts der gleiche sein also das ist ein
dreier her denn weihnachten also ich
werde mein bruder und seinem ansehen
können aber unsere eltern denen wir
leider auch facetime nur sehen können
weil belgien in ein schwererer locker
und ist dass wir hier in deutschland und
da ist wirklich auch besuch während
weihnachten vergriffen aber sowieso hab
das ja war für dich war es wohl mit
eines der schönsten jahre vielleicht
sogar in deinem leben du hast da
heiratet innerhalb wie hast du das
erlebt also ich muss sagen dass dieses
jahr auch so viele schöne momente hatte
das highlight für mich natürlich die
hochzeit mit niklas war einfach ein
traum traumhochzeit und mit damian auch
das erleben zu dürfen mit unserer
klostermühle in friends das war echt
mega beruflich ist es hervorragend
gelaufen dafür bin ich natürlich sehr
sehr dankbar
ja es war ein jahr mit höhen und tiefen
so jetzt kommt natürlich der große
geschenke bahn
dieses jahr will man vielleicht nicht
unbedingt in die geschäfte eingehen
möchte man online bestellen wie sieht
das im hause meist aus in hasen fitter
wird geschaut wird trotzdem in die
geschäfte gegangen mit der online
geshoppt wie kann ich mir das vorstelle
bauen also eigentlich eine mischung ich
weiß dass ich viel online bestellen
werde aber das hätte ich immer gemacht
aber ich finde es auch schön immerhin
noch in diesem zug um
ein bisschen doch diese weihnacht
atmosphäre zu schnuppern
ich finds schade wenn man jetzt die ihr
leben komplett ignoriert weil die
brauchen ist auch an diese zeit und
deswegen werde ich eine gute balance
finden und habe die richtige liste die
duh abarbeiten wo also ich hab ne liste
ja ich habe eine liste und die ist lang
und ich muss anfangen ich habe noch
nichts du hast noch nichts ist hier wohl
aus ich weiß aber heute abend ist in
holland eigentlich der wichtigste
nikolausabend heute kriegen alle kinder
in hollands klingen ihre geschenke und
süßigkeiten aus dass neuer heiligabend
zu ihr sorgen genau aber heute hast du
dir ausreden auch keine geschenke sein
weil du hier bei uns richtig und sicher
mal hierhin dafür und ich sage es aber
ich habe auch heute da haben ja wieder
gefälscht ich bin wieder bei einem herz
für kinder und er sagt manchmal so stolz
auf dich bitte bitte bitte ich hoffe die
menschen spenden so viel geld nicht
unbedingt direkt in deine kamera
belieben bitte spenden sie ein herz für
kinder
wir müssen unser kinderschützenpaar
captain und alles geben was sie jetzt
vielleicht nicht haben dafür sind wir da
bitte spenden sie gleich live bei zdf
und mit der 0 18 02 10 10 10 oder haben
sie vielleicht mit ein bisschen glück
sowie meist anders schritte und dann
können sie auch ruhig das ein oder
andere intime gespräche anfangen oder
man darf sich auch schon ein paar
private sachen fragen dann haben wir
können quatschen über weihnachten über
das jahr sehr gut da freuen wir uns sehr
auf
dabei ist ja ganz ehrlich sehr sehr
gerne schön ist toll aus für sparen
heute abend einfach für durchrutschen
auch gerne noch mal vor der kamera
vorbei ganz genau so ist super ich
machte mindestabstand holler holler 01
02 10 17 das ist ihre nummer für die
promis natürlich auch für die spenden
sind egal was sie spenden jeder cent
jeder cent zählt jeder cent kommt an
auch fünf euro sind vollkommen ok lungen
absolut und ich wollte auch noch mal
betonen alles kommt an wirklich ein herz
für kinder können sie sicher sein
da landet nichts hier bei der gala oder
bei verwaltungen oder sonst irgendwas
jeder cent den sie spenden der kommt bei
den kindern anders ist
ganz ganz wichtig das muss man immer
wieder betont genauso wie die nummer die
du so schön sagt sie doch bitte noch ein
02 10 10 10 das ist ihre nummer zum
glück und vielleicht haben sie mit etwas
glück sind wir am hörer oder vielleicht
auch sogar helene fischer denn helene
fischer wird er heute abend nicht nur
ihren ersten großen show auftritt in
diesem jahr haben sie wird zweimal
auftreten einmal alleine und einmal im
duett mit andrea bocelli und dann sogar
am telefon auch sitzen
ich frag ich glaube ich gar nicht mehr
venedig am meisten freut vielleicht die
zuschauer das schon mitbekommen welcher
name der besonders oft dreht ich betone
aber trotzdem wer noch mal so auf der
bühne ist bei auf die freue ich mich
ganz besonders max raabe zusammen mit
lea einer meiner lieblingssongs in
diesem jahr
sie werden ihnen hier performen zusammen
loredana noch mal eine ganz andere
richtung rap superstar ist auch hier als
wir haben da wirklich aus allen
möglichen richtungen
wir haben ein herz für kinder all stars
die hier natürlich auch ein bisschen
weihnachtsstimmung dann schon reimen
david garrett auf einer der unserer fall
paten der für uns in namibia war sich
dort vergewissert hat dass das geld auch
wirklich ankommt er wird auftreten da
wird auch hier noch auf dem teppich sein
also man redet sich im mund für sich mit
wieviel promis heute abend hier sind wie
viel kraft wir heute abend geht's am
ende hat doch gar nicht oft zu reden und
noch mit flexit mit dieser
plexiglasscheibe versteht und nicht so
viel aber habe ich eben verstanden dass
du mich in den helene fischer fanclub
einfach mal so reingepackt hast das
relativ versteigen sich dass die heute
abend dabei ja und ich glaube millionen
draußen auch wenn fischer ist unser
mega-star aus deutschland aber auch ein
megastar kann man auch sagen große glas
sicherheit schon auf dem roten teppich
und gleich wird sie auch bei uns stoppen
ich sehe familie roth franjo gerona und
den diego und da vorne auch am lhc
simonetti mit einem sakko das wird ja
auch gut stehen ich hab's schon gesehen
und dachte ich würde jetzt nicht
ablehnen wenn das jeder nachschenken
rechte familie zarella sehe ich noch ich
kann gleich ein bisschen weiter kommen
als du noch glasperlenspiel ist auch
schon hier auf dem teppich ist größer
als ich heute 8
das hat dem tannenbaum fehlt so ein
bisschen die spitze oben noch auf dem
kopf bei dir nele ich arbeite noch dass
sie sich so schön in dieser schein ich
kann die ganze den dass meine locken
langsam auseinander fallen ich nicht
weiß ich sehe wie mais haare so gut
halten meine nicht da muss ich noch mal
nach des tieres 08 02 10 10 10 wären
ihre haare justiert können sie jetzt
eigentlich schon mal zum telefon greifen
und etwas spenden und wenn sie kein
telefon zur hand haben dann kommen sie
vielleicht nicht bei einem promi durch
aber sie haben vielleicht internet und
beim internet tippen sie einfach einen
www.bafa.de steht für ein herz für
kinder ganz leicht zu merken punkt.de
und dann können sie auch zum beispiel
über paypal spenden genau oder
überweisung eigentlich fast alle
möglichen arten und weisen können sie
spenden denn uns ist einfach wichtig
dass das geld hier ankommt dann wird es
dann zu den kindern kommen kann und da
vorne sehe ich sie schon zu viert sind
sie sogar gekommen die ganze familie bot
aber der kleinste darauf alle alicia
doch verona hallo komm komm einfach zu
uns nach vorne heute komplett mit der
halle franjo grüße euch heute komplett
mit der ganzen familie auch den geo
hallo und hockey league die hotlines ist
auch bitter weil warum heute mit der
kompletten familie wohnt da sonst
empfehlen wir alleine auf mode ja
tatsächlich ist eine einladung gekommen
dass die vier ports eingeladen sind der
hund leider nicht die kuh leader ist
nicht dabei aber wir haben gesagt
community oft hier also jahr für jahr
und nicht über 25 jahren schon und wir
haben einfach gesagt das ist ja mein
anders auch unseren kindern die u17
ruckes neu auch mal so ein abend glaube
ich erlebt man anders wie vom fernsehen
und das wird ja heute sehr bewegen und
die kinder das sind ja die zukunft um
sich gedanken zu machen was man auf der
welt verändern kann und wenn sie heute
so einen schönen abend erleben auch viel
hochwertiger ist wie viel arbeit
dahinter steckt kann das schön finde ich
auch etwas ganz besonderes für design
und das glaube ich geht heute nicht ganz
spurlos an die beiden vorbei
du hast du bist heute aber auch noch mal
etwas mehr vor allem an einem fall dran
bist freibad in jetzt bei uns ein herz
für kinder kannst du uns
ein bisschen schon dazu erzählen weniger
begleitet hast ja ich bin nach thüringen
gereist und habe in guter im kinderheim
besucht und habe dort ja 17 kinder
getroffen und die haben mich schon sehr
bewegt und mit firmen dürftig drehen und
das wird man auch später im beitrag
sehen es war schon sehr traurig auf
dahin seite auf der anderen seite -
hoffnung gegeben was ich am meisten
bewundert habe ist dass diese dass diese
kinder eigentlich ein alles verziehen
haben also die haben ja wenn man die
geschichten hotel kommt es schon ewig
reise zusammen aber sie haben sachen
erlebt was ich zu sagen dass gewalt in
der familie sexuelle nötigung sie waren
einer psychiatrie sie sie wurden tage
lang in einer wohnung vergessen und wenn
man die wirklich trifft und mit ihnen
redet na dann dann freunde sich und
tragen ein kommst du jetzt jede woche
und die haben einen so sympathisch
aufgenommen und einen so ins herz
geschlossen
und da denke ich mir ja die kleinste
kleinsten die haben alles verziehen und
sind einen anderen weg gegangen wie
viren und deswegen bin ich auch froh
dass die und rocco dass heute alles ein
bisschen miterleben weil der rote
teppich ist ja nur ein kleiner teil
darin werden wir viel zusammen erleben
als familie und ich glaube das können
wir so schnell nicht vergessen
ich finde das total schön warum hat das
ihr gerade so offen darüber redet hier
steigen die tränen in die augen gerade
das ist aber bei euch zu hause so also
da gibt es keine tabuthemen ja also das
bespreche dir auch mit euren sinn also
diego und ich mir sitzen durch zufall
natürlich war der nacht menschen sind
einfach mal durch zufall in der wohnung
und wenn der user hat wie war dein tag
heute und ich erzähle ihnen so was
unglaublich geht das nicht
vor beinahe hätte ich schon interessiert
du hast ja auch in bolivien kinderheim
sehr unterstützt rappaz bewohners casita
und von daher habe ich das von china von
immer mitbekommen dass sie hat ja sehr
viele schon gespendet und einem und da
deswegen bin ich auch sehr nah an dem
thema selbst hören du hast auch
patenkinder in bolivien auf und ich bin
mit kleinen auf andere kenne ich die
bilder aus bolivien mit den ganzen
kindern und von daher wurde schon immer
mit dieser thematik sozusagen daran
geführt und ich verstehe das auch
ziemlich und du warst ja auch mal bei
engel im einsatz sie auch schon etwas
länger her und da waren ja auch ähnliche
sachen und wir sind allgemein auf eine
sehr familie der uns uns ist nicht so
viel egal und wir interessieren uns
schon auf jeden fall für sowas und ich
stelle mir das gerade so herrlich vor
ihr beiden nachts um zwei in der küche
und dann fangen was machst du da bist du
der zeitbedarf damals du stehst dann
schon auch eine perfekte zeit um jetzt
in das geschenk für den papa zu
diskutieren oder so abends nachts die
geschenke abgeschafft wir haben ja nicht
nur noch kinder also ich glaub ich
schenke euch was ihr schenkt euch nichts
mehr durch den eltern noch was aber ja
natürlich als familie würden wir uns
auch super wünsche noch mal ein aufruf
jetzt für alle warum es so wichtig ist
heute abend zu spenden was man kann
okay aber der rocco wollte auch noch
verstärken also hier ist derart haben
die spende vorbereitet auf eine
eigenständige 100 euro ungebrochen die
menschen überzeugen
er hat die tour vorbereitet ist dass es
im eigenen portemonnaie sogar mit hund
zu sagen hatte einkommen erst mal
vielleicht hat schon eine eigene karte
was ist mit den taten steht rock und
monats mit von zwei euro danach gerne
dann hätte ich nicht schlimm wenn du die
nummer abdecken kann
das ist sehr gut mehr datenschutz
so so toll das zeigt auf den fall wie
wichtig ist es dass das kann ich so was
nicht zu hause bringen kindern würde
sagen alles richtig gemacht bei der
erziehung oder alles richtig gemacht 100
euro vielen dank an den kleinsten
spender jetzt hier bei uns auf dem
teppich zu mir und dann wollen wir jetzt
natürlich noch mehr leute dazu anregen
dass jetzt die ihr nachzutun in die
kamera hat sie damit wir alle dass jeder
rasch begreifen
die nämlich als klitschko haben wir
jetzt das halte an aufrufen
also ihr lieben alle die ihr zu schaut
jeden einzelnen euro zählt und jeder
einzelne euro kommt 100 prozent da an wo
kinder wirklich in not sind öffnet eure
ärzten auch wenn die zeiten moment sehr
sehr schwer sind und wir müssen alle
zusammenhalten aber die grenzen der
kleinst am ende der kette dürfen wir
nicht vergessen und deshalb spendet
heute abend fleißig mit 0 18 02 10 10 10
ist die nummer und wenn der kleine rocco
100 euro spenden kann dann können sie
ruhig 105 euro spenden und vielleicht
kommen sie ja sogar bei familie pooth
durch und dann wird auch ein bisschen
geplaudert und am telefon und wir geben
alles sehr schön vielen vielen tagen
viel spaß und wir wissen alle eine hohe
sprechen bände
das ist der anfang an geschehen euro
waren das eben mega vielen vielen
dankeschönabend einfach durchgehen
ich mache wieder den mindestabstand nach
hinten und oder kommt das sage was ich
von weitem gesehen habe was auch der
nele sehr gut stehen würde sie ist ein
bisschen neidisch
ich habe ich vorhin schon gesehen weil
die jungen aber du hast ja auch ein sehr
schönes kleid schön wie geht es dir
heute habt super ich freue mich total
dass das hier stattfindet und wir
mussten dieses jahr auch so viele sachen
verzichten
auch viele wichtige sachen und deswegen
bin ich umso glücklicher dass ein herz
für kinder stattfinden kann
beim stichwort wichtig dass hier ist
natürlich der wichtigste viele modelle
auf jeden fall messen herzlich
kindergerichte warum liegt dir so am
herzen also ich habe ein herz für kinder
das ganze jahr über und das stimmt sie
das ganze jahr über projekte von denen
kinder profitieren sollen habe selber
auch ein kinderbuch geschrieben
zu dem thema und ein herz für kinder ist
selber was was ich jahrelang im
fernsehen angucken durfte als kind und
deswegen finde ich es toll selber anteil
beitragen zu können um hoffentlich
kindern zu helfen was ich hier so schön
finde ist es wird so viel geld gesammelt
und dass wir dann da verteilt wo es
gebraucht wird und das ist ebenso ein
krasser unterschied zu anderen
organisationen dass man halt dass so
viele verschiedene menschen unterstützt
werden hierzulande aber auch im ausland
und deswegen hoffe ich dass heute
natürlich auch sehr viel geld zustande
kommen wie sieht das aus du wirst
nachher bei am telefon sein und die
leute die am telefon sind braucht man
nicht mehr überzeugen nun war es ein
hartes jahr was würdest du all denen da
draußen sagen die sagen wisst ihr was es
ist ende des jahres wir müssen noch
geschenke besorgen jetzt auch noch was
zu spenden bei mir ist es wirklich knapp
also ich kann schon verstehen dass
dieses jahr für viele leute der
herausforderung war und ich glaube das
darf man auch nicht unterstützen weil er
und unterschätzen weil viele leute haben
auch finanzielle sorgen aber ich glaube
wenn dieses jahr etwas beigebracht hat
dann auch was man dankbar sein sollte
für das was man hat und wenn man sich in
erinnerung ruft dass andere menschen
nicht einmal das haben glaube ich
spendet man vielleicht sogar in dieses
jahr leichter als die anderen jahre weil
man selber mal in der situation war wo
man gemerkt hat so fühlt sich das also
an wenn nicht alles rund läuft und
vielleicht sollte man in solchen
momenten daran denken und damit auch
andere menschen unterstützen und sich
einfach wünschen dass man selber nicht
mehr die situation kommt sie gerade
deine gute co-moderatorin freundin
möchte ich schon fast sagen sie die
meist habe es vorhin verraten sie shoppt
am liebsten weihnachtsgeschenke online
erarbeitet eine riesige liste von oben
bis unten ab und hat bisher noch durch
eingeschränkt wie sie das bei dir aus
also ich muss sagen ich bin dieses jahr
sehr sehr früh in weihnachtslaune
gekommen weil ich mal gelesen habe dass
menschen die sehr früh mit weihnachten
anfang
weihnachtsdekoration aufstellen
tendenziell glücklicher sind und ich
dachte mir ich habe schon im oktober
angefangen und ermitteln dieses jahr
habe ich im november schon den
weihnachtsbaum gehabt und ich bin
komplett fertig ausgesagt habe alle
geschenke schon und ich denke so okay
jetzt kann es kommen wo im glück obama
ist auf 10 jetzt schon bei dir oder 7,57
einfach bis weihnachten kirche noch eine
10 hin
sehr schnell haben die hoch wenn du
spenden sammelt recht ja wenn er
hoffentlich ganz ganz viele menschen
anrufen und spenden dann geht die glücks
kalla ganz weit nach oben
vielen dank dass auch für wird er hier
ist und das unterstützt dankeschön ein
kleines spendenaufruf völlig noch
aufholen
dann haben wir auch hier an bitte bitte
bitte ruft an und spendet ich werde mir
auch möglichst viel mühe geben ganz nett
und charmant am telefon zu sein
das schaffst du auf jeden fall vielen
dank rica dankeschön ganz wieder volk
gesagt dass ich gerade so getragen zu
zweit 10.10.10 ist die nummer dann haben
sie vielleicht auch ricardo simonetti an
der strippe und können vielleicht fragen
wo dieses auto gekauft hat jetzt schon
mal und die wichtige frage natürlich ein
herz für kinder es ist ein sehr sehr
wichtiges projekt das betonen die jetzt
die ganze zeit aber warum vor allem auch
in diesem jahr das für niemanden einfach
war
also ich glaube
nicht nur in diesem jahr sondern in
jedem jahr brauchen die kinder und so
hilfe jetzt erwiesen
zweifach eltern und wir kennen auch
kleine wehwehchen und die tun mir schon
weh und ich will gar nicht wissen wie
sehr die eltern daran zu kämpfen haben
und da möchten wir einfach dabei sein
helfen unterstützen
und wie gesagt ja auch in diesem jahr
wahrscheinlich da noch mehr wie sonst
normalerweise würde ich jetzt immer
fragen was war der kleine richtig ist
das ganz einfach herzlichen glückwunsch
noch also jetzt zu viert wie ist es aber
in dem jahr trotzdem gewesen so was
kannte keiner von uns vorjahr und damit
so großen neuen entwicklung mit kleinen
kindern lieber jahr 2020 also ich sage
immer ist es auf jeden fall 2020 wird
immer in erinnerung bleiben bei uns auf
jeden fall auch positiv weil wir einfach
an die geburt unserer tochter festhalten
und letzten endes war 2020 glaube eine
sehr sehr große challenge für uns alle
sehr sehr große herausforderung für die
einem eher für die anderen weniger
aber ich glaube zusammenhalt war es ist
dieses jahr wichtiger denn je erklärt
ihr schon so schön vor dem
weihnachtsbaum es ist ja jetzt schon so
weit wie sie weihnachten in so einem
ganz besonderen jahr bei euch aus
weihnachten werden wir glücklicherweise
dieses jahr zu viert verbringen dürfen
und wir werden auch in dubai bleiben
geht es jetzt um in vier tagen und haben
auch uns dazu entschlossen dort zu
bleiben und dort weihnachten danone der
familie zu genießen umzug starten
natürlich so gelegt dass er bei herz für
kinder noch dabei sein konnte da es ist
wirklich so formation ganz ganz lange im
kalender
position absolute erde das heute hier
sein dürfen letztes jahr aufgrund von
krankheit nicht geklappt da waren wir im
bett deswegen ist umso schöner heute
heute mit dabei sein so sehr gut könnt
ihr bitte auch unbedingt alle eure fans
noch einmal motivieren mit einem großen
spendenaufruf in eure kamera meine
lieben da draussen heute findet ein herz
für kinder statt kinder da draußen
brauchen wir unsere hilfe und jeder der
kann helfen genau bei ein herz für
kinder punkt.de per paypal oder durst
uns einfach an wir sind noch lange nicht
wir sind ein teil davon und ich hoffe
hier auch und wenn er die nummer wissen
wollt dann ist es die 0 18 02 10 10 10
apropos weihnachten apropos nikolaus
habt ihr schon geschenke für euch beide
gekauft oder schenkt ihr euch gar nichts
um ehrlich zu sein ist es vor lauter
kofferpacken komplett untergegangen
wir haben uns ist das süß und vielleicht
bald sie am hörer unter den 18 02 10 10
10 und dann wird gespendet
unterhaltet euch auch ein bisschen mit
den anrufern wurde kommt einfach
hierdurch oder hinter dem kameramann wie
ihr wollt
perfekt nach vorne sehe ich schon die
jungs von bosshoss und ihr später der
abend wird desto mehr strahlst du ja ich
glaube du hast eine nein nicht wenn sie
die strahls mehr du strahlst hoffentlich
bevor du bevor du dieses interview
gleich komplett übernehmen wird
loredana hallo mein name ist martin das
ist nele und nele liegt mir seit gestern
in den ohren dass du kommst die es so
aufgeregt und ich übergebe es in diesem
moment wirklich unangenehm böglmüller
durch fair dass du heute abend dabei
wenn du bist ja auch mami warum ist es
so wichtig vor allem den allerkleinsten
zu helfen
ich glaube ich brauche gar nicht viel
sagen weil ich kein all den schmerz wenn
sie vielleicht nur ein bisschen
schnupfen hat dre schon vorkommen durch
und ich glaube wenn ein kind krank ist
und du nicht wirklich blöd gesagt das
geld dazu hast dein kind zu helfen dann
will ich das gefühl gar nicht kennen ich
bin auch deswegen hier weil ich glaube
wir haben auch die möglichkeit zu helfen
sie verdienen ja gut und es bleibt immer
viel übrig und deswegen ich mache das
sehr gerne uns seitdem wie du gesagt
hast dich mami bin es ist schon ein
bisschen anders also man versteht jetzt
echt wo man meine mama hat damals immer
gesagt ja wenn du mama wirst wirst du
schon verstehen was es bedeutet wenn ein
kind krank ist oder ja schon mega ich
freue mich auf jeden fall hier zu sein
und das unterstützen zeigt uns 2020 wir
alle wissen ein sehr seltsames jahr ein
sehr schwieriges jahr für viele wie war
das jahr für dich was war dein licht
blick vielleicht auch in diesen
schwierigen zeiten
es war für mich glaube ich so wie glück
im unglück weil ich hatte natur
die war ja geplant ich konnte jetzt den
ich spielen wegen hoher warte noch immer
auf die träger war ein bisschen traurig
vor allem für die fans dass ich jetzt
endlich nicht meine erste tour spielen
konnte aber ich hatte zeit für meine
tochter und ich habe die ersten schritte
mitbekommen wo ich mega angst hatte dass
ich es nicht mitbekommen
sie redet jetzt mittlerweile sich krieg
immer alles mit und ich war sehr viel zu
hause und das ich glaube das war so mein
licht dass ich einfach mit meiner
tochter sein konnte und das schlechte
glaube ich war einfach nur dass wir
angst um die gesundheit hat mehr
vielen dank dass du heute abend hier
west und bitte noch mal einen großen
spendenaufruf in deine kamera damit
möglichst viele leute anrufen ich hoffe
dass sie spendet ich bin selber mama ich
weiß was es bedeutet wenn ja ein
bisschen zu viel geld ab dann bitte
spendet loredana den vielen dank 08 02
10 10 10 ist die nummer die sie heute
abend wählen sollen und warum ich so
lachen muss wir haben gerade einen
zettel reinbekommen dass wir uns mit den
interviews bei allen sollen aber die wir
sind alle hier haben so viele
hochkarätige gäste hier reicht das ganze
ist der integrierte loredana dinu vaduz
unangenehm gemacht hat
wer haftet wenn haben wir denn da hinten
doch wir haben
fühle sich und klitschko den kann man
gar nicht übersehen mit seiner größe mit
einem riesigen herzen dass er richtig
trägt und natürlich auch vor sich trägt
denn er hat das herz für kinder herz
dabei aber jetzt direkt bei uns familie
zarella krise sollte um schwarzen
kreuzes gelandet wie herrschte eine
punktlandung sozusagen gut sehr gut hier
sollten wir stehen glaube ich hier sieht
toll aus
die mega-show bahnen auch dieses jahr
war nicht ein einfaches jahr
dann habt ihr es erlebt genauso rechts
und dramatisch wie alle anderen auch
also unsere branche waren sehr sehr hart
betroffen also vor allem bei mir die
musikindustrie und alles was daran hängt
der ganzen rattenschwanz bis hin zum
catering und ton licht und allen und
dann auf der andern seite meine familie
natürlich mit der gastronomie
der hat auch voll abbekommen von der
freizeit also meine eltern meine
eigentlich meine ganze familie ist alles
gastronom und da macht man sich erst mal
wirklich darüber gedanken was da gerade
passiert was gerade passiert auch ist
und man begreift den ernster lage so mit
der mit der dauer der zeit immer mehr
also auch der letzte neue oder irgendwie
nicht so ganz haben will muss leider
sagen dass es muss leider sagen dass es
das alles realität ist also trotzdem du
warst ein riesenglück dass dieses jahr
oder ganz schön dicke landet ja was
machen können wir uns freuen nächstes
jahr geht's los im spätsommer da gibt es
dann die erste samstagabendshow das ist
eine sache die die hat mir tatsächlich
im kopf also die hat mich beflügelt die
sich ja und auch geholfen über diese
schwere zeit
das ist ein erfolg meiner ganzen familie
also angefangen bei meinen eltern
oder meinen großeltern die die nach
deutschland gekommen sind wenn ich sehe
wie meine familie dass alles sich
aufgebaut hat das ist ein wahnsinn das
sind die opfer meiner ganzen vorfahren
meinen eltern meiner gemeinde meine
großeltern und bis hin zu dem einsatz
von uns beiden und unseren kindern ein
erfolg der familie sagen wir mal ja und
ich sehe schon du kommst gar nicht
auszustrahlen haus du bist auch mega
stolze oder ja ich bin total stolz weil
das ist wirklich ein langer weg wenn ich
denke man hat er mit bloßes angefangen
wann hat es aufgehört und jetzt wieder
seit 15 jahren sind vergangen und wir
haben wirklich so vielen gesetz gemacht
dann so für immer auf unser bauchgefühl
gehört im rat haben wir an uns gesucht
wir haben immer das gemacht was wir für
richtig halten und fleiß lohnt sich
immer ja und wird belohnt und ich bin
echt unglaublich stolz auf schon mal
nehmen wir weihnachten kommt bald habt
ihr eure geschenke gegenseitig schon was
ist denn hier los ist dass nicht mehr
viel zeit
ich habe getan haben schon geschenke
hören schon aber ich muss kurz in die
geschenke diskussion einsteigen weil wir
haben gar nicht da das geht gleich los
aber ich habe noch eine ganz wichtige
frage du bist auch freitag heute abend
also jemanden ganz besonders begleitet
kann samstag ganz kurz schon ein
bisschen was zu ferrari
ja ich hab den den kleinen kino
begleitet
der ist aus homburg im saarland da ist
ja auch in der klinik der kleine mann
hat schon mehr zeit leider im
krankenhaus verbracht als zu hause und
hatte schon 13 schwere operationen und
hat eine sehr sehr schwere sehr seltene
krankheit krankheit muss klose das ist
eine krankheit die mit dem schleim im
inneren des körpers zu tun hat er sich
dann auf den organen breitmachte sehr
sehr sehr komplizierte sehr komplexe
sache aber der kleine verliert sein
lächeln mich und ich weiß noch genau ich
kam da anfang ein paar wochen und das
erste was er gemacht hat er kam mit dem
fußball im flur entgegen vom krankenhaus
und die ängste die ich letztendlich auch
hatte ihm zu begegnen
ich wollte alles richtig machen die hat
endlich mit diesem fußball sofort
genommen und wir haben da fußball
gespielt und es ist sehr bewegende
geschichte von dieser familie eben und
ihr müsst bitte alle für den kleinen
china und auch für all die anderen
kinder
bitte bitte spenden sie habe ich das
fast schon gemacht natürlich ein
spendenaufruf wünschen wir uns noch
einmal in die kamera von euch damit
möglich die leute anrufen
auf jeden fall leute wir sind alle heute
hier gemeinsam für einen guten zweck
wir wollen ein fakt hin da eine gute
zukunft schenken und vor allem die haben
wirklich nötig und ganz besonders ja
schon so blöd lass uns das jahr dann zum
ende so gut zum ende bringen
ja genau von meiner seite genauso gerade
in so einer zeit müssen alle ganz eng
zusammenrücken und noch mehr uns an
positiven dingen festhalten dass hier
ist heute abend eine große möglichkeit
gutes zu tun
von zu hause aus von der couch aus ganz
entspannt und gemütlich lasst uns das
bitte ton für die schönsten größten
engel der welt unsere kinder danke
spendet
das schön nur 210 c 10 ich bin ganz
gerührt als ich gehört habe war ich kurz
obst 0 18 02 10 10 10 ist ihre nummer
dann haben sie vielleicht familie
zarella kinokarten dolphins müsst ihr
los
danke und bevor es losgeht einer kommt
noch und den lassen wir nicht vorbei
haben wir die zeit noch klitschko für
den haben wir die zeit und der ist
nämlich noch interviews vorher haben wir
die zeit noch für zwei ganz andere
männer die jetzt bei uns sind dann ist
es wird schon so stress gemacht die
jungs von bosshoss bitte einmal auf das
schwarz und innen her stehen haben aber
es geht nicht wie mister natürlich mein
herz für kinder wichtig egal heute aber
als erstes möchte ich wissen habt ihr
beide schon geschenke für euch beide
gekauft gegenseitig die schneide oder
schenkt ihr euch helfen uns gegenseitig
geschenke und wenn die überreste eines
beginn da ist eine richtige gala ist die
letzte an diesem großen jahren
eigentlich auch die einzige in diesem
büro naja warum seid ihr heute abend
hier warum ist ein herz für kinder so
richtig für euch
wir sind selbst feder wir lieben kinder
wir haben kinder wir sind schon oft
dabei gewesen
jeglicher form bei herz für kinder und
wir können wir haben ja sonst nichts zu
tun
deswegen sind wir natürlich sehr gerne
hier und es ist ein extrem anstrengendes
jahr und gerade für die kinder die auch
jetzt besonders für hilfe brauchen ist
natürlich besonders schwierig wir alle
wissen wir das ist gerade mit betreuung
krankenhäuser oder pflege und kindern
geht es glaube ich noch drei mal
schlechter weil das soziale einfach noch
wegbricht wie sieht man euch weihnachten
aus wir haben schon ganz aufgehört
kleine familie drei personen ja so also
kleiner kreis logischerweise ganz
beschaulich ganz ruhig
machen
ja eigentlich wie immer wir machen jetzt
an weihnachten bisher eigentlich kein
großes bohei mit vielen vielen leuten
und partys aber die weihnachtsferien
sind traditionell dieses jahr nicht auf
dem kalender wenn man nicht weg wandern
skifahren oder so fällt aus wann planen
ihr im nächsten jahr was ist euer wunsch
habe ihre natur im nächsten jahr oder
musste was geschoben werden in diesem
jahr bei euch habt ihr eine touristin
der besucher frage für muss ich also
wieso den witzen christen muss sich
anpassen dass gerade auf tour wir haben
eine tour geplant im sommer nächsten
jahres das wäre die tour aus diesem jahr
und wir hoffen sehr dass wir das im
nächsten jahr auch wirklich angehen
dürfen wir drücken die daumen auf jeden
fall
und jetzt natürlich am ende der
spendenaufruf wichtigsten leute und ganz
viele firmen zusammen sind am telefon
und wir gehen da auch nicht weg bevor
wir nicht 20 millionen kasten so sieht's
aus und das bitte noch einmal
diese kamera besitzen heute am
spendentelefon 22 das ja jetzt gilt's
ladies and gentlemen spendet ruft an wir
wollen 20 millionen ja vorher gehen wir
nicht
20 führen dass der handel 0 18 02 10 10
da haben sie mit viel mit etwas glück
die jungs von voß eine große spenden
sondern dankeschön geht entweder bei uns
vorbei oder dahinten vorbei wie es euch
beliebt dankeschön 0 18 02 10 10 10 da
vorne sehe ich wladimir klitschko meine
güte ist der großen inne
deswegen habe ich nur deswegen habe ich
heute so hohe schuhe an damit genau das
also hast und die nummer hat martina
schon so oft gesagt ich finde man kann
die mich auf genug sein bei jeder cent
kommt an jeder cent zählt sagt uns noch
einmal 18 uhr 2010 letztes jahr haben
wir 18 millionen 97.000 und ein paar
zerquetschte die ich jetzt nicht mehr
zusammenbekommen zusammengekommen dieses
jahr soll das natürlich getoppt werden
wir gerade gehört ja 20 ps erreicht auch
als ich sagt 19 millionen und wenn wir
auf 18 millionen kommen ist es auch toll
manuela schwesig ich da vorne gerade
ministerpräsidentin meines heimatlandes
und zwar von mecklenburg vorpommern frau
schwesig können sie sich noch ganz kurz
nach vorne bitten ich grüße sie und es
ist ja eine traumhafte maske
das leopard oder wie sie brauchen sie
nicht auch bei uns können sie sich gerne
abnehmen frau schließlich geht es ihnen
stehen dank mir geht es sehr gut und ich
freue mich sehr heute hier zu sein weil
es seit vielen jahren ein
herzensanliegen ist kinder zu
unterstützen
und es ist toll dass trotz bewohner
heute die möglichkeit besteht dass wir
alle wieder ein herz für kinder zeigen
wie sind sie setzten heute abend auch am
telefon wenn man sie anruft wie
überzeugen sie das vielleicht noch fünf
euro mehr raus gedrückt werden ich muss
sagen meistens braucht man die leute gar
nicht überzeugen jeder gespendet
wirklich viel und was ich besonders
berührend finde es wenn sich zum
beispiel auch ältere rentner melden und
sagen ich habe nicht so viel rente aber
ich möchte auch gerne was geben und dann
zählen auch fünf euro und ein anderer
kann vielleicht 50 oder 500 ich setze
darauf dass jeder der die kinder
unterstützen
vielen vielen dank dass sie heute abend
hier sind wir hoffen dass auch bei den
aktien von ganz viel dabei rumkommt
dankeschön sich aufladen sich schön
sonst so schönen abend so und jetzt
bevor wir abgeben ich habe gesagt ich
gehe nicht weg bis dabei und steht
deswegen jetzt bei uns vladimir
klitschko guten ein herz für kinder ein
projekt das sie schon ganz lange auch
mit begleiten vor allem in diesem chor
naja warum ist es so wichtig dass jeder
von uns jetzt an die kleinsten denkt und
sein geldbeutel dafür vor allem öffnet
es ist ganz wichtig die kinder zu
unterstützen vor allem während der
pandemie viele leiden an der pandemie
und vor allem auch die schwächsten und
wer sind die kinder und vor allem in
diesem jahr ist ganz wichtig kindes
unterstützen und all die projekte
ich bin davon ein riesen fan von ein
herz für kinder als organisation weil
jedes entgeht in die projekte und nicht
in die verwaltung
das stimmt und sie sind natürlich auch
am telefon wenn man bei ihnen anruft was
ist da ihre strategie und möglichst viel
für die kleinsten zusammenzubekommen
im grunde genommen jeder hat schon
entschieden wie viel man spenden will es
wird kein langes interview geben
wie viel man spenden will sondern im
laufe des jahres ist weiter niemand an
gewisse zahl an konkrete zahl ich habe
niemals mal gefragt ob sie nicht mehr
geben wollen
letztendlich wie gesagt gut dass die
menschen immer noch ein herz haben rufen
an und spenden und vor allem in diesem
jahr ganz wichtig sind vor allem in
diesem jahr verglüht schuld das bitte
noch einmal in diese kamera noch einmal
den spendenaufruf jeder cent zählt bitte
spenden so einfach ist das nun als 8 02
10 10 10 und dann haben sie vielleicht
mit etwas glück gleich ab 20 15 live mit
klitschko am telefon den deutlichen satz
abend ist daher schon dabei sind
dankeschön und gleich geht's los und wir
haben auch immer nicht alle promis ihr
gehabt haben mussten vorbei weil es
einfach so viele tatsächlich sind aber
du hattest loredana ich hatte logan
erfrischung
ich sag jetzt mal wenn ich ihn auch sehr
falls wir gleich abgeben müssen damit
sagen dass sie da sind kathi hummelt
simone thomalla nachdem du vorhin ja
sophia thomalla stolz dass nichts schief
sophia thomalla wir versucht seine
plakate mit lisa und lena sehe ich da
auch also lisa lena tatsächlich auch
freikarten haben sich da auf einer ganz
besonderen pferde range umgeschaut das
gleich auch im zdf und hierbei bild
natürlich zu sehen dann was die beiden
da gemacht haben was für ein projekt sie
also ganz besonders unterstützen welches
projekt mit ihrem geld dann unterstützt
wird so wir hören es gerade wieder wir
beginnen in wenigen minuten mit der live
show und die gäste müssen jetzt schon
mal alle ihre plätze einnehmen um dann
für sie am telefon zu sein unter 01802
ccc mal wenn sie da anrufen dann können
sie fünf euro 10 euro 20 euro natürlich
je mehr desto besser aber auch kleine
beträge sind immer gut und kommen vor
allem anja jeder einzelne cent kommt bei
den kindern an für die er bestimmt ist
und am schönsten bisher fand ich es
kommt bei den kindern als kommt von den
kindern oder rock opa 300 euro
gesprungen sein ganz eigenes geld hat
sogar sein portemonnaie und seine kinder
kreditkarte mitgebracht also der kleine
hat alles zusammengekratzt und das
können sie ganz bestimmt auch ist es
kein einfaches jahr gewesen aber jeder
betrag hilft den kindern weltweit ein
herz für kinder unterstützt hier in
deutschland aber auf der ganzen welt der
begehrt war beispielsweise
namibia für uns um zu sehen wie dort ein
waisenhaus ausgebaute wie die kinder da
auch jetzt während dieser pandemie leben
also wirklich öffnen sie ihr herz und
ihren geldbeutel
so sieht das aus und ich muss jetzt mal
kurz die regie fragen wir bleiben noch
ein bisschen drauf weil die nähe hat
eben schon sorgen gemacht hier weil
wladimir klitschko als ob wir als ob wir
gleich abschalten und habe das auch in
den abteilungen drauf so dahin kommen
die nächsten jedermann da ja lisa und
lena die schon ihr herz direkte da
tragen wo man es hat genau mich nicht
hinter der brust sondern auch bewusst
wie sorgen grüße euch hallo ich habe
schon ein bisschen erzählt ihr seid ja
auch weil partner in diesem jahr habt
eine ganz besondere pferde range besucht
ich wollte noch nicht zu viel verraten
aber vielleicht könnt ihr uns ein
bisschen mehr erzählen was sie da
gemacht habe ich genau wie dürften die
petra besuchen den reiterhof betreibt
drei therapien angibt für kinder mit
erkrankungen und behinderungen
und das heißt so schön weil ich davon
ich wusste dass es wirklich so aktiv und
mich gar nicht so gut auskannte hier zu
sein hat mir klingen spenden am telefon
sitzen dann natürlich auch und sie haben
es jetzt schon öfter gefragt was es da
wie macht man das am telefon versuch
madonna 12 euro mehr herauszukitzeln
oder wie es am telefon was euer plan für
heute abend also wir suchen uns auf
jeden fall bei jedem zu bedanken
er spendet man gucken vielleicht kann
man wissen was aus handeln aber ich
meine jeder cent ist wichtig das ist
allgemein cool dass die man spendet und
super morgen ist nikolaus basis wollen
wir beide habt ihr schon die geschenke
untereinander oder wisst ihr sowieso was
der andere dem anderen schenkt weil man
die ganze familie habe ich schon aber es
wird nicht also ich bin ehrlich ich bin
so ein mensch bin mal kurz war knapp
aber ich bin noch gute sache und dann
dann ist mit online schwärme dann eher
ins geschäft noch schneller und den
stress
im glück amerikanerin 2020 ich glaube
ich ja heute nach der sendung der sich
für diesen tipp und ein paar hier die
kamera ihren spendenaufruf
bitte bitte spenden weil wirklich jeder
cent zählt egal wie viel sie spenden
da sind sie sich eigentlich vielen dank
dass ihr heute abend da seit wir hoffen
ganz viele leute erreichen euch
natürlich dann auch am telefon und
martina die nummer noch einmal für zwei
ccc und dann habt ihr vielleicht dann
haben sie vielleicht zu hause
lisa und lena und können vielleicht mal
fragen ob sie sich jetzt schon ein
geschenk für einander ausgedacht haben
wenn sie spenden 01802 ccc viel spaß
heute abend und sie hoffen dankeschön
eine große spenden so lange soll ebenso
einfach die durchmischung der meister
und wenn alle geschenke
du fragst du jeden so ich habe das
gefühl du suchst nach inspiration für
deine heimlichen wird jetzt durchbrochen
ich habe tatsächlich schon 12 geschenke
aber noch nicht alle und ich habe so ein
bisschen angst dass der online-handel
dieses jahr nicht hinterher kommen wird
und darum wird nicht auf ich auch das
schicksal ereilen ich muss auch in einen
kleinen job aber um mich geht es heute
abend nicht sondern um die herrschaften
die da hinten auch noch kommen
david garrett in der meedia gewesen hat
kalorien sondern hat jetzt auch schon
gar nicht auf zu sprechen
er hat vorher schon unsere noch eine
sendung vorher wir wollten heute hatte
ich den ganzen tag für sie da sein das
heißt die erste social media show gab
schon mit khartum mit jetzt kommt david
garrett noch ein interview macht ja
vorhin noch wir wollen natürlich dass so
viele leute wie möglich hören was er zu
sagen hat über dieses wichtige wichtige
projekt ein herz für kinder und auch
sein eigenes jahr waren namibia und
vielleicht kann ich schon mal sagen dann
muss er gleich ganz in 410 wenn die zeit
knapp wird es ist ein projekt das noch
letztes jahr schon begleitet haben und
da können wir ihnen ganz besonders gut
zeigen wo das geld tatsächlich ankommt
wie das geld verwendet wird in jeder
rede ist so schnell ich komme überhaupt
nicht hinterher sagt ist vorbei alles
gut alles gut solange wir noch drauf
sind sind wir drauf und vielleicht haben
wir also dann noch glück ist das da
hinten barbara schöneberg
barbara schöneberger in einem traum von
silberner was ist das in einem camp auf
jeden fall wie eine superhelden ja
herrlich vergab sie es auch wieder am
starken spenden warb sie es hier jedes
jahr an staat und treibt die spenden ein
und da vorne sich gerade wer wird gärten
nähert sich uns nun als 80 2 ist die
nummer die sie wählen müssen mit der
10.10.10 am ende dann können sie spenden
was sie wollen und mit etwas glück haben
sie stars am apparat wie elias ambacher
wenig übrigens ganz am ende um teppich
auch schon sehen kann warum siehst du
eigentlich mehr als ich sehe ich stehe
so ein bisschen besser glauben das ist
größer bis katie holmes redet sich um
kopf und kragen nach vorne
barbara schöneberger auch aber das kann
sich ja auch und die turniere haben wir
auch gleich hier am start auch window
städtisches alle reden zu viel redet zu
viel die rede so viel alle plappern hier
aber wir klappern um den guten zweck so
sieht's aus den frust und ich heute am
meisten tatsächlich max raabe und lea
max raabe ich ganz vergessen der ist ja
hier noch heute ist ein guter tag um
glücklich zu sein ist einer meiner
favorite in diesem jahr gewesen gute
laune egal wie belastend wie wie
dramatisch dieses jahr manchen stellen
einfach war und loredana hier zu haben
war jetzt auch manchmal ein bisschen in
die andere richtung und dann davon geht
aber manchmal treten zusammen auf und
singen mein einer meiner favorite aus
diesem jahr also da freue ich mich sehr
drauf wir haben so einige premieren in
diesem jahr wir haben florian
silbereisen der als erstes mal war ein
herz für kinder ist und er bringt gleich
jemanden noch mit sack und pack das ist
thomas an dass die beiden haben in
diesem jahr ein album veröffentlicht was
direkt auf platz eins gegangen ist und
heute abend werden sie einen song aus
dem album sing und tausenden 1 100
tausend kerzen brennen
ich hoffe ich habe es jetzt richtig
gesagt wir sind gespannt wie sich hinter
gesteigert gerne das sah hallo grüße
dich du stehst so was kennt landung auf
unserem schwarzen kreuznach also ich als
ganz schön bist du bist feierte bei
harry gehen auch in diesem jahr war es
in namibia und kannst vor allem den
zuschauern zeigen wo das geld ankommt
richtig und kannst deswegen allerbesten
erzählen dass das geld wirklich daran
kommt ja also lena hat ja schon
letztes jahr einen preis hierbei ein
herz für kinder bekommen da gab es schon
sehr viel unterstützt und ich habe auch
gesehen was mit dem geld schon gemacht
worden ist
allerdings zeigt immer noch sehr viel
bedarf das auszubauen
ich finde lena es steht auch darüber
eine ganz ganz tolle person ich glaube
da kann jeder etwas von meiner ruhig ist
wirklich selbst hat so großzügig mit so
viel leidenschaft mit den kindern am
werk und ich bin da echt wirklich
berührt als ich das persönlich habe
sehen dürfen ich muss sagen ich habe den
kleinen beitrag schon gesehen und war
auch sehr gut und vor allem natürlich
das ganze auch in der kommune pandemie
jetzt passiert und man sagt wir alle
wissen dass jahr war auch für uns nicht
einfach aber natürlich bei den kleinsten
die trifft es noch mal ganz anders vor
allem die die passt nichts haben wie
schwer war dieses jahr also für die
vielen kinder denen du dort hilft es war
sehr schwer die suppenküchen waren
geschlossen die schulen waren
geschlossen also wir hatten echt sehr
sehr große probleme haben mittlerweile
fast doppelt so viele kinder im
kinderheim als vor der pandemie also wir
merken das schon ganz schön krass da
unten also ist natürlich umso wichtiger
dass jetzt noch mehr geld zusammenkommen
jeden fall
und du trittst heute auch auf bist
sowieso bei ein herz für kinder schon
lange dabei warum ist ein herz für
kinder für dich so wichtig um so eine
herzensangelegenheit wegen solchen
menschen wie lena das ist mal ganz klar
sagen also sie echt großes vorbild
ich glaube für alle menschen da draußen
wirklich diese eine selbstlose art zu
haben nicht diese konsumgesellschaft die
wir mittlerweile doch irgendwie sehr
auslegen die in deutschland da wirklich
ein absolutes gegenteil aber im
positiven und das ist einfach
beeindruckend und ich freue mich dass
diese geschichte heute abend auch
erzählt wird wir uns auch sehr ein
spendenaufruf bitte unbedingt noch
einmal die kamera genau von denen die
wissen wo es ankommt möchtest du habe
ich keine anfragen
ja in namibia haben wir sehr viele
benachteiligte kinder und wir möchten
auch jetzt gerade aufgrund von corona
diesen kindern noch mehr helfen
bitte spenden sie ich kann ja eigentlich
nichts dazufügen außer zu sagen dass ich
das vor ort live gesehen habe und
natürlich ein stück weiten wir das noch
mehr ans herz geht als der beitrag den
man sieht aber ich kann nur sagen das
geld ist in den besten händen
das ist ein fantastisches projekt mit
einer fantastischen frau und ich kann
nur die daumen drücken dass ganz viel
zusammenkommt für dieses tolle diese
tolle sache da seid und vielen dank für
deine tolle arbeit
ich weiß gar nicht wie emotional das
ganze ist ja noch da ist weil ich hab
den beitrag gesehen und ich bin
normalerweise nicht so nah am wasser
gebaut aber das war schon nicht einfach
zusehen und es zeigt aber auch das geld
kommt an wenn man wo anruft bei der 0 18
02 10 10 10 und wir hatten eben schon
manuela schwesig ministerin von mimo
vorpommern hier auf dem roten teppich
und julia klöckner
nein nein ich doch leider ist das
vielleicht gleich zu unseres schwarze
körper ganz kurz kommen könnte
damit wir vor der gala dem eimer
frankreich guten abend vdv warum ist ein
herz für kinder so wichtig vor allem in
diesem jahr
mona hat sehr viele menschen getroffen
ja ein herz für kinder lässt einfach den
scheinwerfer auf das lenken was wirklich
wichtig ist es in unsere kinder ist in
die familien und es sind gerade die
kinder denen es nicht so gut geht und
die auch besonders unter corona zu
leiden hatten und deswegen ist ein ganz
wichtiger abend und ich freue mich sehr
darauf wir wollen natürlich von allen
noch einmal einen spendenaufruf haben
denn die telefone sind schon
freigeschaltet bitte noch einmal an
unsere zuschauer
er liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
nichts was du für kinder tust ist jemals
verschwendet und deshalb jeder einzelne
euro zählt heute abend vielen dank dass
sie spenden vielen dank dass sie mit
dabei sind
und einen wunderbaren abend für sie alle
ich gehe auch nicht gefällt ist sie
heute haben dabei sind dankeschön
dankeschön sagte uns 13.10.10 und dann
haben sie vielleicht die frau glocke am
telefon aber vielleicht auch die brücke
volk genau
oder vielleicht elyas m'barek die nicht
dort noch sehe barbara schöneberger
kathi hummels hier sind schon noch
einige die auf dem teppich sind bevor es
gleich losgeht und ich guck mal ob ich
party hits von alleine hinter der kamera
wäre schlimm wenn don johnson hat sich
einen schritt zurück durchs gesicht
leider so gar nicht nah bei dir stehen
dem tanklager gerade selber für euch
moderierte jackson ist nicht weit aber
wir haben da sitzt alles ein bisschen
ich höre ja so schlecht und sie hatten
ja nochmal ton der über lautsprecher kam
deswegen habe ich was versteht aber hier
hat alles perfekt lief alles besser kann
na ja schon vorher schon moderiert dass
es gerade gesagt setzt sich also ganz
besonders ein jetzt gleich auch am
telefon
warum ist ein herz für kinder so wichtig
weil ich selber mama bin und weil ich
ein ganz ganz großes herz für kinder und
das schlimmste für mich ist wenn ich
traurige kinderaugen sehen und wir haben
wir gerade auch schon ein spieler
gesehen in der bikestation ich finde
einfach dass sind so so so kleine dinge
die auch nicht viel geld kosten kann
kinder einfach so schnell glücklich
machen und letztes jahr von 18 millionen
euro gesammelt das muss man mal
überlegen es kommt auch 100 prozent der
spende an
und deswegen ist ein herz für kinder
großartig und ich bin jedes jahr dabei
und ein musiker vor allem schnellen
aufruf in diese kamera leute bitte
spendet jeder euro jeder cent kommt an
und es ist so leicht gutes zu tun und
die kinder die brauchen uns so jetzt
musst du sofort am telefon wir werden
hier jetzt schon langsam bisschen wo
darf ich jetzt vorbei gab es an uns
vorbei partie am samstag beim
vorbeigehen nicht zu dicht und das
aber hallo wie eine superheldin habe ich
schon gesagt hey du oder ich habe
unheimlich dass ich habe das posieren
nicht verlernt ich habe es noch mal ganz
klar sagen im letzten jahr ist ich hatte
ja nicht viel übung aber ich habe es
noch teurer ist auch sehr viel magie
drin und ich weiß nicht ob es verraten
darf ich habe schon bei der probe
gesehen heute passiert auch ein bisschen
magie naja wenn sie auf die bühne kommt
ja die spenden warb sie muss jedes jahr
natürlich auch was neues einfallen
lassen und das haben wir auch gemacht
und es geht primär wieder darum inkasso
babsi mäßig den leuten das geld aus der
tasche zu ziehen weil wer hierher kommt
muss natürlich mit allem rechnen so und
da genau hake ich ein aber nun ist es
dieses jahr ein schweres jahr ist karola
ja gibt es das besondere taktik die man
anwendet nee gar nicht die leute hat mir
überhaupt gar keine gelegenheit die
kohle auszugeben haben aber weiter
verdient preis so gerade in der
unterhaltungsindustrie sag ich mal vor
der kamera hat man ja weiterhin
gearbeitet und deswegen bin ich dafür
dass davon heute abend mindestens zehn
prozent an mich abschließen das sind
schlagende argumente auf jeden fall für
die promis die hier sind können sie noch
einmal aber ein zuschauern auch draußen
sagen warum sie anrufen sollen ja trotz
natürlich auch zu spenden so liebe
zuschauer es gilt für nur die die jetzt
gerade eingeschaltet habe für all die
anderen die haben es wohl hoffentlich
schon mitgekriegt es findet heute abend
die große veranstaltung ein herz für
kinder statt sie rufen jetzt an und
spenden irgendwas damit dann hinterher
eine schauspielerin über sie sagen kann
hier hat jemand angerufen und er hat nur
fünf euro von seinem wenigen geld
gespendet und das wird mich besonders
wenn sie diesen satz hören dann gilt er
ihnen sie können aber natürlich auch
mehr oder sie wenden sich direkt an mich
ich nehme auch das geld entgegen
natürlich 7 1 8 und 2 10 10 10 und dann
sehen sie auf jeden fall oder vielleicht
hören sie im hintergrund barbara
schöneberger wie sie vorbei schweben
wird abend 02 10 10 und ich glaube
nehmen wir den herrn berg noch mit oder
müssen wir zu machen also mir wurde noch
nicht gesagt müssen zu machen also
warten während das bedeutet meistens
arbeitet ja dann schreien sie einem
sonst auch wir warten jetzt noch mal im
moment würde ich sagen oder also darf
nun nicht mehr so lange bei ard
shriver heime rüber dann kriegen wir
auch noch indirekt in die sendung elias
selber auch einfach die perfekte
überleitung vergessen ich hab grad schon
gesagt du bist feierte auch und brice
einfällt was eine unserer fälle
begleitet noch einmal ganz besonders von
einer china
kannst du uns da ganz kurz in einem fall
setzt nochmal 10 was du gemacht hast ich
arbeite in erfurt und das ist ein ganz
ganz tolle junge der hut und ist die
ganze gerade die krone total isoliert zu
hause und kann seine schulkameraden sich
sehen keine schule besuchen und es hat
mich sehr traurig gemacht zu sehen dass
der junge zum einen diesen
schicksalsschlag mit der krankheit
erlebt und zum anderen die ich mal
irgendwie das haus verlassen kann seine
freunde sehen kann so isoliert ist und
alleine und die tolle erfindungen ein
roboter den er von zu hause aus steuern
kann über einen laptop und damit am
unterrichtsgeschehen teilen und seine
kollegen seine kameraden schulkameraden
sieht und die noch sehen auf dem screen
und er dadurch jetzt einfach wieder so
ein bisschen mehr an dem ganzen
sozialleben man im schulunterricht
teilnehmen
es hat mich sehr bewegt und ich fand es
schön ihn zu besuchen kannst du dann
sehr gut und jetzt den letzten
spendenaufruf hier bei uns auf dem
teppich von ihren direkten oft nicht
noch mal fragen ob alle geschenke
zusammen
nein ich habe noch gar kein einziges da
waren einfache antwort und jetzt auch
der große spendenaufruf an wen die
zuschauer
hallo alle spenden also ich meine hand
habe schon gehört das ist ganz einfach
ich glaube man kann über paypal ist so
sieht das auch sagt es gibt telefone und
die bestechung endet ist 08 08 02 und
dreimal die 10
ich werde auch spenden unbedingt und ich
hoffe das ganze gesprächen
zusammenkommen und und alle können in
der vorbereitungszeit was gutes tun
insofern tut es elias wir hatten sie
schöner sagen können wir haben wir
hoffen auf eine große spendensumme danke
dir einfach wie durchrutschen und dann
wenn sie schon so 0 18 02 10 10 10 oder
www.ee h
k punkt de dann können sie ehrlich das
hat eben schon gesagt auch über paypal
spenden genau und elias das war der
letzte aufruf hier bei uns wir geben
jetzt ab in die große gala moderiert von
johannes b kerner und all die leute die
sich irgendwie haben und noch viel viel
mehr sind da auf der bühne für die
kinder für die kleinsten können sie
natürlich live hier auf bild de nicht
nur zdf bleiben so einfach dran dann
können sie auch hier um 20.15 jetzt
gleich die große ein herz für kinder
spendengala sehen es war ein traum
vielen dank ihr heim weihnachtsbaum der
herzen und ich würde dich gerne ein
küsschen links und rechts geben mit
plexiglas wir hoffen auf ganz viele
spenden ihnen einen wunderschönen abend
vielen dank dass sie dabei waren bleiben
sie dran ganz genau